let's go to the state of Georgia I hope
I'm pronouncing this correctly is it
Hannah is that the right pronunciation
yeah sorry Hi
um it's uh Hannah is just spelled weird
because my uh Mom's family is oh okay um
but yeah so
sorry I'm super nervous you're doing
great so Georgia like I was uh I wasn't
born here but I grew up here like even
when I moved in high school I came back
here for college and to be with my
family and friends and like just the
right like the rate they're going like
I'm like as a person able to get
pregnant in a month like a mother of a
daughter I'm honestly petrified to stay
in Georgia or really even the us if it
keeps going down the route we're going
um and so like but I'm sure like I have
like an idealized version of other
countries
so like I was just wondering like are
there any countries that you're like
confident in
like their you know level of Education
the government regulation yeah like
standard of living things like that and
then I did have one other question so
listen here here's the thing there's a
um a metric called the human development
index okay and I hear you saying you
know you're worried about Georgia but
maybe you're worried about the entire
U.S I do think it's important to
understand that in the U.S if you search
for U.S states ranked by HDI you will
find
that at the top of the list you have
Massachusetts Connecticut Minnesota New
Jersey New Hampshire Colorado these are
states whose HDI is equivalent to that
of places like Switzerland Norway
Iceland Hong Kong Australia Denmark
Sweden
and those are all very good places to be
human development index is basically a
kind of like a blended metric that takes
into account life expectancy education
income health a bunch of it's like a
blended metric those States I mentioned
and really everything from like you know
roughly like Oregon and up which is like
you know about 18 states or so it's not
that different than some of the best
places in the world to live the problem
is that at the bottom of the list it
gets very bad right and it's mostly red
States it's Mississippi West Virginia
Alabama Arkansas Kentucky Louisiana
South Carolina Tennessee Oklahoma you
get the picture George is down there as
well
things are much much worse so one thing
is it's hard to move to other countries
so I would look at is there a state you
can move to where abortion rights are
safe education is better access to
healthcare is better and the answer is
there are many such States if you want
to look internationally then you're
looking at some of the countries I just
mentioned but it's quite difficult to
move to some of those places
yeah well I think I just worry more
about like not even just like down to
the particular States but like what
they're coming after a national level I
understand I understand the truth is
even with that there are many states in
which you are protected against a lot of
those things not all of them certainly
Social Security you're not going to be
protected no matter what state you're in
if they gut it but uh you know it you
don't have to run away screaming just
just yet I'll tell you if the time comes
for that
from Democrats
sure
um so like would trying to like I know
that obviously they've like a lot of
them have very confused moral compasses
yes but like if you're trying to appeal
to them like on a human standpoint
because like obviously saying you're
wrong or like you're not you know you're
you're dumb stuff like that isn't gonna
appeal to them it's just gonna irritate
them so like maybe trying to go about
like uh Democrats coming from a
standpoint of you know I'm sorry that
these politicians have manipulated you
and lied to you to steal you know to
take your vote for their own personal
power and greed I like that idea and
then like present like actual real life
how it would affect like Democratic
policies would affect your daily life
not just these two broad or too
anecdotal versions of these scenarios I
totally understand the idea I think it's
a good one but understand that a lot of
these folks aren't going to want to
accept that they were tricked and lied
to but your instinct is a good one your
instinct is not to just start beating
people over the head with facts Hannah I
gotta run but I really appreciate the
call
yeah thank you all right Hannah from
Georgia that does it for calls today we
will take calls again I promise you that